You're in a lot of trouble you want to get out
of here right what if i can offer you a chance
what does my chance require someone's changing the
proper flow of time you're here to help me catch
this guy who is it someone very familiar you gotta
be kidding me he could be hiding anywhere anytime
how nice to meet you it is adorable that
you think you could possibly manipulate me
i'm 10 steps ahead of you
I never do it again
now streaming only on disney plus
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
loki episode 3 trailer video i know there's
all kinds of questions about what's going on with
this new variant version of loki because there's
a lot of conflicting information and references
especially in the end credits which call her by
a totally different name so i'll explain what's
going on with that it's not quite as confusing
as it seems if you're brand new to the channel
i'm doing videos for all the episodes be sure to
subscribe to get them i'm also doing a giveaway
for disney plus memberships all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and just leave all
your predictions for episode three on the video
careful for spoilers for everything that's
happened on the show so far if you haven't
seen episode one in episode two but at the end of
loki episode two loki meets this variant finally
that had been killing all the tva men and it was
revealed at least at first as a female version of
loki with a twist a really big twist because the
latin american ending credits actually name her as
sylvie as in sylvie lushton from the comics
who's the second version of enchantress
so of course everybody got really confused because
they spent the entirety of the first two episodes
canonizing her is a loki variant but then why
are they calling her sylvia in the credits
if that really is her name the really quick answer
to that is that there's actually a clue earlier
in the episode loki actually found out what her
name was already on the variant report like if
you zoom in enhance on here it actually lists her
as sylvie laufedottir so she is still a loki like
an alternate universe version of loki lofisson and
they called him that when he went in for his trial
because lafay is his father even though he
identifies as an odin son he calls himself that
during avengers infinity war usually when people
call him a lafay sun it's when they're trying to
demean him or when they're trying to hurt him or
punish him or refer to him in a bad way but that's
just the beginning of her character but that
means that she's still a loki variant she isn't
the enchantress but i'll explain how they're sort
of combining a bunch of different things to form
her character tom hiddleston was talking about
her character after the episode came out so i'll
explain what he said in relation to his version of
loki and what they're doing with her on the show
but she rigged all the time reset devices that
she's stolen from the traps that she'd been
setting sending them to various places in time and
space inside the mcu timeline to just create as
many branching timelines as possible effectively
blowing apart what you think of as the sacred
timeline creating as much chaos in the sacred
timeline as possible forcing the tva to then send
out every single hunter that it has leaving the
timekeeper citadel almost completely undefended
a lot of those different places that the time
bombs went to are big easter eggs i listed them
all during my full episode 2 video so i'll add
a link for that at the end of this and down in
the description below because some of them are
really cool like she sent one of the time bombs to
ego the living planet to vormir to the cree home
world several of them went to earth during various
points in history and then this new character
who's kind of a combination of a couple different
marvel characters unfurls her hood and tells loki
that the plan that she's enacting isn't about him
at all then waves with his mischievous smile
and takes off escaping through another portal
tom hiddleston said that in this moment the reason
why his loki pauses obviously he's furious here
because he's kind of been one-upped a little bit
and then follows her through the portal is mostly
because his curiosity gets the better of him
like in this moment he said that his loki wasn't
charging after her to stop her or fight her he's
just really really curious about this new variant
and what she's up to like you are interesting i
would like to know more about this so it's more
that idea of loki doing something bad something
good kind of in between state that loki is always
in and more to that based on all the evidence
so far and the foreshadowing that they've been
beating us in the face with the first two episodes
this new character the variant isn't really evil
or good either and she's not the main villain of
the story the way that mobius and the rest of the
tva were hyping her up to be during episode one
and episode two so right after this you also see
a bunch of the new episode three footage it's
basically loki right on her trail you see him
in front of a couple different portals during
different apocalypse events because as they had
figured out the variant lady loki enchantress
character here had been traveling through
apocalypses to hide her temporal signature which
they've been using like time travel fingerprints
to locate specific individuals anywhere in the
timeline anywhere in the multiverse also talk
about that idea too how did they explain the
multiverse if there's a single sacred timeline
that was one of the things was confusing people
the first couple of episodes because even before
she created all these branching timelines there
was a multiverse in the mcu they explained during
the first doctor strange movie a long time ago
the thing is though is that different marvel
directors and different writers have different
ways of describing the marvel multiverse so in
the doctor strange movie the ancient one talked
about the multiverse in the context of alternate
dimensions as he's on that sort of grand tour of
the multiverse he's traveling through different
dimensions instead of what you would normally
think of the multiverse was just slightly
different looking versions of earth for instance
like infinitely different versions of worlds that
all bear some resemblance to each other then
during avengers end game they also talked about
branching timelines as if they had become fully
alternate realities like more new universes of the
multiverse now in the loki series though they're
kind of trying to clarify how all that works
so when they say sacred timeline that means that
there's this predetermined course for the current
version of the multiverse so think about the
sacred timeline as this giant roaring river
that the multiverse is inside of the river is so
big and strong that within each different universe
you can have events play out in slightly different
ways with those little ripples in each different
universe not being strong enough to change the
course of the larger river this actually might be
a physical representation of the sacred timeline
inside something like the fourth dimension like
in the fourth dimension you would perceive the
sacred timeline as a three-dimensional construct
like the bifrost so at least at the beginning of
episode three it seems like loki is still chasing
after this new variant and trying to learn more
about what game she's up to mobius at the end of
episode one so they were chasing after loki we're
going after another you that's why i'm picking you
then before they went to the rocks cart they said
it again so here's why i think she's still a loki
even though her technical name is sylvie
laufeydottir but when she kind of laughs when loki
tries to call her by the loki name so for instance
when loki calls her loki in the episode she
scoffs and says don't call me that then when wunmi
mosaku's hunter b15 asks loki if he thinks the man
buying flowers in the hurricane is a variant loki
says possibly but normally he be wearing a suit
impeccably dressed then loki talks about how
the magic she's been using this whole time
even though it's color-coded green just like
loki's magic is enchantment mobius canonizes
that all the loki variants don't have to look the
same or even have the same powers that's why they
show you a couple loki's that don't look anything
like tom hiddleston at all like viking loki
satyr looking loki the hulk looking version
of loki just to set up the twist that this new
variant could be another loki that looks nothing
like r loki and has totally different powers so
here's where we get to the part of them combining
characters sylvie in the name is a reference to
sylvie lushton from the comics the second version
of the enchantress she was created by lady loki
but she was an american character living in a
version of new asgard on earth that they just
called little asgard in broxton sophia dimartino
is the actress who's playing this version of the
character and during episode 2 it seems like
her variant character is wearing a costume that
seems more inspired by i cole's costume with the
broken horns from the comics but she has blonde
hair in an american accent the difference between
i cole and lady loki is that ikol was meant to be
a non-binary version of the character who would
just flip from male to female looking versions
on the fly so for instance like this comic
book panel here this is from the exact same
scene just to show you how they don't identify
as male or female just flipping back and forth
whereas lady loki was the spirit of regular loki
in the body of sif now none of those versions of
the character were super sexualized or had any
romantic relationships or anything like that
but what it seems like the loki tv show is doing
is trying to combine the sylvie lushton character
in some of her powers with the concept of the ico
version of loki in their feminine looking persona
like genderqueer loki that looks like this and
i think the reason why they might be calling her
sylvie is because they thought it just sounded
better than calling her ico like they wanted
to give her an actual name that wasn't loki to
differentiate her from our main loki so that
fans wouldn't get confused and they also wanted
her to be a non-binary character so they didn't
want to simply just call her lady loki because
that wouldn't be accurate either because this
character doesn't think of herself as being just a
man or a woman which i think is part of the reason
why you see her jumping so many different bodies
male to female during this sequence when she's
fighting loki and when she says don't call me that
when he calls her loki she just doesn't want to be
defined as a loki specifically even though she
was born to lafay so she is technically a loki
she just wasn't born a man and when a version of
odin adopted her or when she was adopted she was
given the name sylvie instead of given the name
loki like i still think that she's a loki variant
and the writers are just combining aspects of the
icole and enchantress characters to make her feel
as different from our main loki as possible like
owen wilson said none of the variant loki's have
to be very similar like some of them are vastly
different and what tom hillston had to say about
the character like the whole point of this new
character reveal was to be like this crazy fun
house mirror situation where loki sees himself
and is completely confounded like wait what what's
going on with all of this as he chases after her
with the idea that this new variant knows more
about the secret of the time keepers than she's
letting on like hunter c20 kept repeating that
line it's real it's real i think they will answer
what she was referencing during episode three
tom hiddleston also said he's most hyped up
for fans to see episodes four and five because
in those episodes the series is supposed to take
some dramatic left turns and i think that's when
they're really getting into the idea of what's
actually going on with the timekeepers the sacred
timeline like it's all a big lie a farce just as
loki predicted space lizards this is ridiculous
in some of the other characters like ravono rents
layer and mobius will also learn that something is
not quite right with the time keepers like in the
credits here there's a scene where the elevator
reaches an access restricted floor that might be
where they find the secret behind the timekeepers
i'm also expecting a bigger reveal with miss
minutes as well because the tva is this big
farce then miss minutes is like the jarvis that
helps everything run she'd have to be connected
to that too it's like the reveal of the rox cart
so the town has this very happy sounding name
hiding this very terrible sounding corporation so
i think it's the same thing with miss minutes like
she's so happy it's probably big misdirect meant
to hide the sinister nature of what's actually
really going on these scenes with the wreckage
of the ship in the same scene with the starship
enterprise looking spaceship saucer behind here
seems like loki in the landscape of another
apocalypse as they travel through all these
different portals and this scene of him sitting
down to talk to lady loki seems like it's in the
middle of some giant mining camp which might be
connected to these other scenes too i don't think
it's vermeer but we'll find out about that pretty
soon and i will do a bigger video on lady loki and
enchantress so if you do have more questions about
the character just write them in the comments
below like i said i think that she's still a loki
variant but i think they're combining a bunch of
different marvel characters including enchantress
stuff for her character congratulations joshua
meyer you're the giveaway winner for my last
big loki video please email me on the about page
of my channel so i can get your contact details
everyone click here for my full loki episode 2
video and click here for my full loki episode 1
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!